Have you ever wanted something so
bad and then it actually happens
but it's not as great as you imagined it
come on i don't know what's going on with you
she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo you are
just know whatever you are facing
you don't have to do it alone cosmic
Welcome back everyone marvel just dropped a brand
new ms marvel trailer we'll break it down i'll
explain how it's connected to what we just saw in
doctor strange two because we just finally saw the
inhumans in the mcu but it's way more connected
to what's going on in the mcu with secret invasion
nick fury the kree skrull war like the whole
secret invasion of it all as well as the marvels
movie so i'll explain how it's all going to work
there's a bunch of easter eggs if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get everything
they'll only be six episodes but it'll be starting
right as i finish my obi-wan kenobi episode videos
but the big thing with ms marvel and the mcu is
that they've changed her backstory she used to
be an inhuman in the comics she was doused
with this giant terrigen bomb that thanos
set off in new york city atalan the inhuman
city was located in new york at this time
but so far in the mcu up to doctor strange too
we hadn't really done a lot of inhuman stuff
there was that inhumans tv show which people
try to argue is canon but kevin feige and
the marvel studios people who didn't have any
kind of hand in making it treated it like the
redheaded stepchild like you inherited this
now you have to acknowledge it in some way
recently in doctor strange 2 they finally did that
bringing anson mount back as a version of black
bolt it was a different version from the inhumans
tv series it was a little more comic book accurate
his costume was a little closer to the comics they
killed their version of thanos but the real trick
is that we got to see black bolt use his ability
to kill their version of doctor strange but it
was all part of that storyline trying to say that
doctor strange could theoretically be one of the
worst possible things to happen to the multiverse
if he went the wrong way all the illuminati scenes
were meant to be these fun cameos from a bunch of
different groups in the comics like fantastic four
x-men obviously captain carter from the what if
series but it was more there for the cautionary
tale to show how far they could go if they went
off the rails like wanda completely rolling over
all of those characters but now there was any
question inhumans are technically canon to the
marvel cinematic multiverse so if we have inhumans
why aren't they doing ms marvel as an inhuman
there's a very businessy explanation for
that we were supposed to get an inhumans
movie a long time ago but that wasn't really
kevin feige's choice to make an inhumans movie
it was put on the schedule when it was still like
pearl motor kind of calling the shots at marvel
it was meant to be his big thing that's why it
wound up being a tv series kevin feige took it
off the schedule when that happened so then
we got a version of captain marvel we got a
version of monica rambeau during Wandavision
they're building up this big Kree Skrull war
in interstellar space in a slightly different
part of space but it's still in the same galaxy
so much of ms marvel's character is connected to
the captain marvel carol danvers character in her
related universe of characters that they wanted
to do that in the mcu so rather than do like a
whole bunch of other projects explaining who the
inhumans are and kind of setting their group up
like you had to do three or four more tv shows in
another movie what it seems like they've done is
just explained the kamala khan ms marvel is just
a regular person who gets a version of the nega
bands which is what the original captain marvel
named marvel wound up using in the comics they did
a version of marvel in the mcu during the original
captain marvel movie but it was played by annette
benning so it was a big twist on the character and
the backstory was a little bit different too so
even though they're changing how her powers work
they're trying to make them look kind of like the
comic book powers and going back to the original
captain marvel comics to do it but they're trying
to set this big space saga that's going on inside
the mcu like guardians of the galaxy right now
is our big space based movie in the mcu they're
trying to do more of those there's actually talk
of them doing anova disney plus series right now
too they haven't said which version of nova it's
going to be but you can see they're just trying
to do more space based disney plus series more
space-based movies that are not guardians of the
galaxy you probably heard that they just shifted
the release dates of some of the marvel phase 4
movies next year what happened is is that ant-man
3 quantum mania with them going up against a legit
version of king the conqueror from the comics the
one we saw at the end of loki season one that's
happening in february now and it switched places
with the marvel's movie captain marvel 2 which
is coming out in november the reason why they
shifted captain marvel 2 to the end of the year
is because they want the secret invasion tv series
which is teasing this big kree skrull war and
secret invasion from the comics before captain
marvel 2 to help lead up to what's happening
during that movie everything is connected so now
you see like ms marvel is sort of feeding into the
secret invasion series a little bit with what's
going on with nick fury in the skrulls and then
that's going to lead into captain marvel 2. that's
why when people ask kevin feige what's going on
with ms marvel's powers why they look so different
he says they're trying to make their powers come
from a similar source and look relatively similar
during captain marvel 2. even though the nature of
their powers is quite a bit different so captain
marvel is more like this cosmic battery like
she can just absorb and redirect energy we've
never really seen the upper limit of that i think
they'll go full binary with her character during
captain marvel 2 they got close during the first
captain marvel movie even though monica rambeau's
powers look a little bit similar she can also
absorb energy and redirect it it's a little bit
different for her she can absorb recreate and
become any kind of energy that she's capable of
understanding is one of the reasons in the comics
she could theoretically be invincible like she
could become as powerful as the infinity stones
because they give off a certain kind of energy
as long as she could fully understand the infinity
stone energy which is so complex that it's highly
unlikely that's why during one division you see
her going up against wanda absorbing her chaos
magic which is a really big deal people like
ghostwriter can also eat magical spells so i
know people are like does that mean the ghost
writer could also eat chaos magic probably and
now we have kamala khan ms marvel that seems like
she's using the nega bands which somehow wound
up in her family they were created by the kree
they basically turn mental energy into physical
energy which is why a lot of her abilities in
the trailer seem like her comic book abilities
we make all the simpsons jokes because she says
in bigen her inhuman powers in the comics make it
seem like she just enlarges parts of her body or
her entire self when she's fighting people but the
really scientific explanation for her powers
that they use is that she's actually pulling
energy from her future self through time to power
herself up in the past like she's borrowing energy
from the future from herself the nega bands that
she's wearing on the show obviously much simpler
explanation the big thing with nick fury is that
he's actually trying to prevent a full-scale
secret invasion situation from the comics that's
why in the comics the whole idea was who do you
trust and it was like every single avenger could
theoretically be a skrull in disguise during the
secret invasion series it sounds like it's going
to be a different sect of the skrulls like these
religious zealots that are trying to pull off a
smaller version of secret invasion and it seems
like amelia clark is actually playing a version
of the skrull empress so you have this kree skrull
war different sides both sort of building up to
a larger conflict trying to use earth as this
outpost that's where secret invasion comes in and
it sounds like that sort of spill over the top
during the captain marvel 2 movie she probably
winds up landing on nick fury's radar because
it seems like there are a couple antagonist groups
on the series and one of them is more connected to
the us government than the other this just seems
like a regular evil supervillain group amongst
many inside the mcu trying to take her nega-bands
to use their power for her own this group with all
the tactical suits in the guns seems like it's
connected to the government one of the villain
groups is called nice nice they're meant to be
like marvel's version of ice but for superheroes
it sounds like all this trouble happening in
jersey city will land her on nick fury's radar
and then he'll realize what's going on with her
wielding this crete artifact and that'll sort
of dovetail her plot with what's happening in
secret invasion and then obviously during the
captain marvel 2 movie most of the monica rambeau
teaser at the end of one division was meant to
dovetail with the marvel's movie captain marvel 2.
it wasn't meant to be a big secret invasion teaser
even though that is happening before captain
marvel 2. he'd like to meet with you where
now i'm not expecting kamala khan or monica
rambeau to show up during secret invasion
unless it's some sort of post-credit scene just
teasing its connection to the next big movie
most of the other ms marvel stuff is dedicated to
establishing her character so that you understand
why she becomes a part of whatever this young
avengers team winds up being in the mcu now ms
marvel was not a member of the young avengers
in the comics there'll be a couple changes but
mostly they're introducing the core roster through
all these different disney plus series and movies
like we just got done seeing america chavez
during doctor strange 2 but she wasn't a member
of that original roster but basically we have
kate bishop hawkeye from the hawkeye series we
have a version of patriot from the falcon winter
soldier series if they want to bring him back
he was isaiah bradley's grandson he gets a measure
of the super strength basically passed along
genetically from isaiah bradley's super soldier
serum we had a version of kid loki show up during
the loki series they could always bring him
back for young avengers obviously we just saw
a version of billy and tommy we have a multiverse
now so depending on which version you think would
show up billy and tommy from the comics which are
part of that original roster they could introduce
a version of hulkling during the secret invasion
series but they don't necessarily have to and they
could always do a version of iron lad if they want
to as a young version of kang because we're going
to see many different variants of kang in the mcu
because it sounds like he's going to be our big
figure heading into secret wars the whole idea of
the kang multiverse war is that it's connected to
the incursions different universes fighting with
each other technically i mean they're colliding
but they're kind of fighting with each other
because of the kang multiverse war they could
either do iron lad from the comics who was a young
version of kang earlier in his timeline or they
could just put riri williams iron heart on the
team there been a lot of theories that maybe she
could be a female gender bent version of young
kang but i'm not expecting that that would be a
huge twist it would be pretty cool but i'm not
expecting it then in ant-man 3 we have the new
recast version of cassie lang who is stature in
the young avengers one of the other reasons for
them swapping the marvel phase 4 movie so we get
ant-man 3 in the version of kang the conqueror a
little bit faster is because so much of this
is spinning up with the incursions in secret
wars they just want to get to that a little bit
faster just to tease the connections like oh this
is what this is all leading to this is the person
who's all behind this we'll get more trailers with
some more footage for ms marvel as we get a little
bit closer my obi-wan kenobi episode videos will
start in a couple weeks though so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
ms those everyone click here for all my doctor
strange 2 post credit scene video avengers 5
secret invasion teaser videos and click here for
my brand new obi-wan kenobi darth vader trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!